[Music]
hi everyone its charlie big surprise
there's another game of Thrones teaser
trailer they released this morning
they're calling it the official tease so
I don't know if that means that there's
gonna be another big trailer before the
season starts whatever they wind up
dropping I'll totally make videos for it
but this as you can tell no dialogue
just meant to be very atmospheric and
give you a tone for what the battle is
going to be like because the season is
getting started the giveaways now are
gonna be for HBO now subscriptions all
you have to do to enter those or just be
a subscriber and leave a comment on the
video there were also a bunch of brand
new screen grabs from episode 1 so I'll
break those down after I talk about this
footage the teaser is meant to be the
next morning after this big battle with
the White Walkers and the night King
goes down so it starts on the flag of
Winterfell blowing in the wind in the
courtyard that you've seen in all the
episodes before then as the camera pans
to the side you get a full view of the
devastation from the battle with the
night king and the White Walkers
everything is wrecked snow is covering
everything like winter has come so it's
snowing but you look at the ground in
all these preview images of Tyrion
inspecting everything the first couple
of episodes then you look at the ground
here and it's just another reference to
the idea that the night king brings
winter wherever he goes as the camera
starts to float around you start to see
very specific objects in different
places referencing each of the big
characters so the first one is what
seems like dragonglass
arrows we know the Gendry is making you
much of dragonglass weapons for everyone
there's a close-up shot of what seems
like the forge area where again drew was
making weapons and the other trailer
with all the fire pits turned over
everything just wrecked then they moved
to the wolf statue which is a reference
to the direwolves ghost is gonna be back
for season 8 no worries but I don't know
how many episodes he's gonna be in this
area will seem familiar you see the hand
of the queen pin the Daenerys gave to
Tyrion back during season 6 this is the
dog kennel where Tyrion woke up in
season 1 episode 2 because he got too
drunk the night before they were making
fun of them also notable because this is
the same area later in that episode
where he slapped the crap out of Joffrey
the camera moves around again to a
different area there's a quick window
what seems like the armory of the
kennels maybe the storeroom there were a
lot of shields and supplies to
in the background behind these bars but
the point is mostly to show you Arya
Starks needle stuck in the ground in the
middle of the frame here the camera
flows up on top of the walls you see
turned over firepits notice the details
on the walls here these spikes actually
look a little bit like wolf ears but
they're just part of the practical
defences built into the walls just
making it that much harder for people or
undead whites in this case to climb over
the walls the camera moves to another
part of the upper levels in the
courtyard and you see the exotic bird
feather that robert baratheon left at
lyanna stark's tomb during season 1
episode 1 we also saw it in the season 8
teaser trailer a couple months ago when
Jon Snow was walking past her statue
that teaser wasn't meant to be actual
footage of the show the real bird
feather in the context of the show was
taken by Sansa from lyanna stark's tomb
during season 5 when she was down in the
crypts remember she and Littlefinger had
that conversation in front of lyanna
stark's statue so I think this scene
here the exotic bird feather is a
reference to Sansa because all the main
characters get little references and
objects all over the teaser and sanso is
one of the bigger characters this season
so bird feather Sansa floats to the
ground and you notice at the bottom of
this staircase is brands wheelchair
turned over and smashed the camera
creeps along the ground you see Jamie's
golden hand behind it as the camera
refocuses is Daenerys special dragon
chain that she was wearing during all of
season 7 the camera continues on towards
the South Gate and you see the wind blow
the snow away uncovering Longclaw and
then behind that as a frame widens you
see the shape of the night King slowly
walking south through the gate with the
winds of winter seemingly following him
foreshadowing that he's heading south to
King's Landing now that he's seemingly
destroyed Winterfell Winterfell has
fallen so it's just implying a very grim
future for Winterfell and everyone there
but you asked where the bodies if these
characters are all supposed to be dead
in this what happens to people killed by
White Walkers oh oh yeah you know light
bulb goes on but really this teaser is
just meant to be very atmospheric and
very ominous this isn't exactly the way
things are going to go down even though
this looks like an actual scene from the
episode just because you see all these
main characters objects strewn about the
field of battle doesn't mean that
they're dead or dying that being said I
am expecting a couple big deaths during
this big Winterfell battle but I think
that most of the main characters will
probably make it
that next big conflict to south at
King's Landing we don't know exactly the
timing of everything but I am expecting
another battle in Episode five so there
will be more than one battle during
season eight issues of this Winterfell
battle is supposed to be the longest one
this is the one that they're hyping up
is their version of the Battle of Helm's
Deep so the real question is is how long
does the night King survive because
there's definitely more than one big
battle so the reason has to be some
twist in this episode three battle where
he makes it south to King's Landing but
they wind up fighting off a lot of the
army of the Dead Winterfell winds up
getting destroyed but most of the main
characters wind up crawling away still
alive I think largely what's gonna
happen just based on what they're
implying here is is that this will
whittle down their forces in the north
so that by the time they wind up in a
situation where they're in a conflict
with Cersei they're different forces are
a little more evened out because right
now the majority of armies in Westeros
are collected up in the north so Cersei
that's why she had to hire the golden
company because she's badly in need of
more troops moving on to the new
screengrabs I believe these are all from
episode one from different scenes so you
see Daenerys was surgery in the
courtyard at Winterfell
maybe this is right before she walks up
to me at Sansa you see Jorah with ser
Davos probably right after that moment
where Daenerys walks up so it's just the
two of them you see Starks soldiers in a
knight of the veil in the background
just watching them there's a couple
different shots of Daenerys and Jon Snow
in the courtyard together either before
or after this big meeting because look
at her winter coat here with Jorah just
seems like a new version of the one she
wore last season with red in it just
made to look almost exactly the same
just a slightly different color though
but now look at her with Jon Snow here
on her shoulder it seems like she's got
this extra wolf pelt or bear pelt
whatever animal pelts she's wearing so
maybe while they're there he gives her
some extra layers because it's extra
cold and she's so used to living in the
east where it's super hot all the time
so maybe these scenes of her with Jon
Snow outside because you see them later
in different places outside of
Winterfell is after the scenes of her
with Jorah inside this room here so it
seems like there are multiple different
scenes here unless Daenerys is wearing
this dress that's a little bit different
underneath this white coat it's kind of
hard to tell without us actually getting
a scene with her taking that coat off it
seems like these pictures are her
meeting with Sansa inside who we now
actually see the other side of that
frame so you can see Sansa wearing her
brand-new
dsm armor gear she is not messing around
this season the looks on their faces
make it sound like this is all the drama
that people have been worried about like
who we're gonna have to cringe our way
through this hopefully it doesn't last
more than a couple episodes there's
another scene of Daenerys and John snow
seemingly away from Winterfell somewhere
else outside where it seems like he's
showing her something and she's really
excited by it without seeing the other
side of this frame just guessing what it
is that she's looking at the only things
around Winterfell that are that
spectacular would be the landscape
itself so maybe she just finds it very
beautiful but there could be something
really cool that's different on the
other side of this we'll find out pretty
soon you get another shot inside the
Great Hall Winterfell where it looks
like they're all meeting trying to argue
with each other about what they're gonna
do next you see Yan Royce the little
bear Brienne and sir Davos sitting next
to each other there's another shot of
Tyrion from that same scene with his
crazy look on his face like he can't
believe what's going on
Daenerys behind them - also with a
similar look like she can't believe
what's going on there's a separate shot
of Varys in the back of a wagon this is
probably at the beginning when they're
arriving at Winterfell looking like he
just can't handle the cold like I was
not made for this he's from the east
that's where he grew up but he's also
spent the majority of his adult life
since he started working for the Mad
King as the master of whispers living in
the south so he's just not accustomed to
any of this cold weather then you get
another new shot of Cersei on the Iron
Throne in her new outfit with those new
shoulder pads with Qyburn sitting next
to her investment to be it but let me
know in the comments if you spotted any
other Easter eggs in these new scenes
that I didn't mention in the video I'll
be doing more regular game of Thrones
bonus videos later this week obviously
there's all the big Marvel Avengers
endgame stuff that drop if you have
special Game of Thrones videos you want
me to do just let me know in the
comments below I'll name a new giveaway
winner when I post new Game of Thrones
you can click here to watch that other
new trailer Easter Egg video that I just
posted for all those new scenes and you
can click here to re-watch that brand
new Avengers endgame trailer thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see
tonight